THE FIRST IMPEACHMENT WITNESS
APPEARING ON CAPITOL HILL TODAY.
IT COMES AS PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
JOE BIDEN CONTINUED TO ATTACK
EACH OTHER OVER UKRAINE.
HERE'S THE LATEST.
FORMER SPECIAL ENVOY TO UKRAINE
KURT VOLKER TESTIFYING BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS.
MEANWHILE, HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
CHAIR ADAM SCHIFF SAYING HE IS
FACING NEW SCRUTINY AFTER IT WAS
REVEALED THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAD
CONTACT WITH THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE BEFORE
FILING THE COMPLAINT.
HERE IS THE PRESIDENT'S LATEST
ATTACK ON SCHIFF AND BIDEN.
>> SCHIFF HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
A LIAR.
WE HAVE KNOWN IT FOR THREE YEARS
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN TRYING TO
IMPEACH FOR THREE YEARS.
HE'S A STONE COLD LIAR.
IF THEY WERE HONEST ABOUT IT,
START A MAJOR INVESTIGATIONS OF
THE BIDENS.
LIKEWISE, CHINA SHOULD START AN
INVESTIGATION INTO THE BIDENS.
WHAT HAPPENED TO CHINA IS JUST
ABOUT AS BAD AS WHAT HAPPENED
WITH UKRAINE.
>> Juan: BIDEN IS FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST PROMPT ATTACKS BUT
RAISING NEW QUESTIONS BY
ADMITTING HE TALKED TO HIS SON
ABOUT UKRAINE.
>> THIS SPECIAL INTEREST FUNDING
HIS ATTACKS AGAINST ME.
I'M NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DESTROY ME.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO DESTROY MY
FAMILY.
I TALKED TO MY SON.
WE HAVE COMMUNICATED.
HE LIVES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE COMMUNICATED A COUPLE TIMES.
LOOK, THERE IS ZERO, ZERO, ZERO,
ZERO, EVIDENCE OF ANY ASSERTION
BEING MADE.
>> Juan: OTHER DEMOCRATS GOING
AFTER TRUMP AS WELL CLAIMING THE
PRESIDENT IS SCARED OF
IMPEACHMENT.
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT KNOWS
THE ARGUMENT THAT CAN BE MADE
AGAINST HIM AND HE SCARED.
>> HE'S ACTUALLY OBVIOUSLY
MOTIVATED BY FEAR.
>> CLEARLY HE'S AFRAID FOR THE
PUBLIC TO SEE EITHER ONE OF
THOSE THINGS.
>> HE'S AFRAID OF JUST HOW BADLY
HE MAY BE BEATEN IN NOVEMBER.
>> Juan: DANA, I WAS STRUCK
THAT THE PRESIDENT, PEOPLE
SAYING YOU SHOULDN'T OF CALLED
AND TALKED TO THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT ABOUT GETTING DIRT ON
JOE BIDEN.
TODAY HE SAYS OUT LOUD CHINA,
I'D LIKE YOU TO GET SOME DIRT.
>> Dana: HE IS SAYING THE
QUIET PART OUT LOUD AND IT'S
DIFFERENT.
BASICALLY HE'S SAYING OKAY,
AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU DECIDE IF
THIS IS WRONG.
SOME DEMOCRATS WILL SAY THERE IS
A LAW ON THE LAW SAYS YOU CAN'T
DO THIS.
BUT THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
SAYING THOSE LAWS AGAINST
CORRUPTION AS WELL.
HE'S BASICALLY PUTTING IT OUT
THERE.
I DON'T THINK HE'S AFRAID.
YOU CAN ALWAYS TELL WHEN THE BAT
PHONE, THE BAT SIGNAL HAS GONE
OUT.
EVERYBODY SAY THE WORD OR PHRASE
AND YOU GET A GOLD STAR.
THE THING ABOUT SCHIFF HAVING
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT
BEFORE, I THINK THE
NANCY PELOSI, HER DEPUTIZING HIM
TO BE BASICALLY THE SPOKESPERSON
ON THIS IS NOT A CLEAR-CUT WIN
FOR HER.
THE PARITY OF THE PHONE CALL,
THAT HE LED THE MYSTERIOUS
HEARING WITH, IT KEEPS COMING UP
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THEN THERE'S A QUESTION OF WHY
WEREN'T YOU COMPLETELY
FORTHCOMING?
I THINK THEY HAVE A GOOD POINT
THAT THEY CAN SAY THE
WHITE HOUSE HAVE A HEADS UP
OTHER WHISTLE-BLOWER ACCOUNT
BECAUSE THE CIA HAD GONE TO THE
WHITE HOUSE LAWYERS FIRST OF ALL
BEFORE THEY WENT TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
SO THAT GETS MORE COMPLICATED
BUT I THINK SCHIFF IS THE
SPOKESPERSON FOR THIS, NOT GREAT
FOR NANCY PELOSI BUT I DON'T
THINK SHE HAS OTHER GOOD
OPTIONS.
SHE'S PROBABLY GOING TO HAVE TO
DRIVE THIS TRAIN HERSELF.
>> Juan: JESSE, THE QUESTION
DANA RAISES IS ONE A LOT OF
PEOPLE'S MINDS.
IS IT WRONG OR IS IT ILLEGAL?
WE KNOW TODAY THAT THE CHAIRMAN
-- CHAIRWOMAN I SHOULD SAVE THE
FEDERAL ELECTION COMMITTEE
RE-TWEETED THAT YOU CAN'T DO
THIS, THAT IT'S ILLEGAL TO ASK
ANOTHER COUNTRY FOR HELP,
ANYTHING IN VALUE IN TERMS OF
GETTING DIRT ON A POLITICAL
OPPONENT.
OUR SENIOR JUDICIAL ANALYST
JUDGE NAPOLITANO, HE SAID THE
SUMMARY OF THE PHONE CALL WITH
THE PRESIDENT ZELENSKY OF
UKRAINE SHOWS AND I'M QUOTING
"CRIMINAL AND IMPEACHABLE
BEHAVIOR."
>> Jesse: I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH JUDGE NAPOLITANO
AND I WOULD LIKE TO HOLD UP
ANOTHER TREATY.
THIS IS A TREATY WE HAVE SIGNED
IN 2,000 WITH CHINA FOR
CORRUPTION AND CRIMINAL THINGS
THAT WE CAN ASK THEM ABOUT AND
WE CAN PULL DOCUMENTS FROM.
JUST BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HAPPENS
TO BE RUNNING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT DOESN'T MAKE HIM ABOVE
THE LAW.
HE COULD DROP OUT TOMORROW AND
THEN TRUMP COULD ASK CHINA?
GET OUT OF HERE.
YOU ARE SAYING THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT ON THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT AND THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT CAN'T ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE BIDEN FAMILY BECAUSE
HE'S A POLITICIAN?
IT'S CRAZY.
I BELIEVE TRUMP, ANY SORT OF
VIOLATION.
IT BOILS DOWN TO TRUMP IS
DRAINING THE SWAMP AND THAT'S
WHAT THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO
IMPEACH HIM FOR.
HE'S GOING TO SWING FOR THE
FENCES.
HE'S GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN AND DO
THIS IN THE SUNLIGHT AND HE'S
GOING TO SAY WHY ARE YOU TRYING
TO IMPEACH ME?
LET THE AMERICANS VOTE ON IT.
THE CHINESE THING ALSO UNCOVERED
INTERESTING FACTS ABOUT HUNTER
BECAUSE HUNTER IS IN BUSINESS
WITH JOHN KERRY'S SON-IN-LAW A
HEINZ AND WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY CUT A DEAL WITH A CHINESE
COMMUNIST BACKED COMPANY FOR
$600 MILLION FOR AN AUTOMOBILE
FIRM AND YOU KNOW WHAT THE
CHINESE COMPANY HAD DONE BEFORE?
STOLEN AMERICAN TECHNOLOGY AND
USED IT ON THEIR STEALTH FIGHTER
JETS AND DO YOU KNOW WHO LET THE
DEAL GO THROUGH?
JOHN KERRY.
WHEN HE WAS SECRETARY OF STATE.
ALSO WHILE JOE BIDEN WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AFRAID TO SAY
THAT THAT IS ZERO EVIDENCE OF
CORRUPTION, HE PUT THAT TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND YOU THINK
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY YEAH,
NOTHING TO SEE HERE?
THAT'S CRAZY.
THERE'S A LAUNDRY LIST OF BIDEN
FAMILY MEMBERS FOR SALE.
YOU LOOK AT HUNTER, LOOK AT HIS
BROTHER.
$1.5 BILLION DEAL IN IRAQ WHILE
JOE WAS THE POINT MAN FOR IRAQ.
THE WHOLE THING IS CRAZY AND IF
YOU LOOK AT WHAT HILLARY CLINTON
WAS, WHEN SHE WAS RUNNING FOR
SENATE IN 2000 IN NEW YORK,
BILL CLINTON PARDONED ALL OF
THOSE PUERTO RICAN TERRORISTS SO
SHE COULD GET THE PUERTO RICAN
VOTE.
OR 1999 WHEN RUDY WAS MAYOR AND
HE WAS CONSIDERING RUNNING FOR
SENATE AGAINST HILLARY CLINTON,
BILL CLINTON SENT THE FEDS TO GO
INVESTIGATE RUDY AND THE NYPD.
THERE IS NO CORRUPTION THERE?
OR HOW ABOUT HILLARY WHEN SHE
WAS SECRETARY OF STATE OR
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT, HER
FOUNDATION IS GETTING TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
MOROCCO, SAUDI ARABIA.
THAT'S NOT FOREIGN INTERFERENCE?
COME ON.
>> Juan: OKAY.
>> Dana: AND NOW TOOK
COMMERCIAL BREAK.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: KATIE, THE NEWS OF
THE DAY THAT WE CAN POINT TO IS
KURT VOLKER, FORMER SPECIAL
ENVOY TO THE UKRAINE, MENTIONED
IN THE WHISTLE-BLOWER COMPLAINT,
GOING TO CAPITOL HILL AND WHAT
WE HAVE HEARD IS THAT HE
TESTIFIED AND HE WARNED
RUDY GIULIANI NOT TO BELIEVE
WHAT HE WAS HEARING FROM VARIOUS
PEOPLE IN THE UKRAINE WHO HAD
INVOLVEMENT WITH CORRUPTION,
PROSECUTION.
HE SAID THESE PEOPLE AREN'T
TRUSTWORTHY.
>> Katie: I THINK IT'S HARD TO
MAKE A DECISION ABOUT TESTIMONY
DONE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS BECAUSE
IT'S GOING TO BE POLITICIZED,
ESPECIALLY BY DEMOCRATS OR
RUNNING THE SHOW ON THIS
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY WHICH IS
LIKE IMPEACHMENT BUT NOT
IMPEACHMENT BECAUSE IT DOESN'T
HAVE THE LEGAL BACKING THAT THEY
CAN GO TO THEIR LEFT FACE AND
SAY THEY ARE CALLING PEOPLE IN
FRONT OF CONGRESS TO GET
INFORMATION.
THEY CAN LEAK SELECTIVELY WHAT
THEY WANT TO.
I WILL HOLD OFF ON MINE JUDGMENT
OF THAT.
I WANT TO SAY JESSE, YOU SHOULD
DO A "ONE MORE THING" THAT IS
TREATIES WITH WATTERS.
THIS IS BRINGING ATTENTION TO
ACCUSATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
WRITTEN IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
FOR OVER A YEAR, THE NEW YORKER,
"NEW YORK TIMES" ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN'S DEALINGS.
BRINGS OF THE ISSUE OF
CORRUPTION AND JOE BIDEN NOW HAS
BEEN INCONSISTENT IN HIS ACCOUNT
OF HIS TALKS WITH HIS SON.
NOW IN THE CLIP HE SAYS ZERO,
ZERO, ZERO EVIDENCE OF ANY
CORRUPTION OR WRONGDOING.
WHEN YOU SAY ZERO, ZERO, ZERO,
YOU BETTER BE CORRECT BECAUSE
WHEN SOMETHING COMES UP IN THE
FUTURE ESPECIALLY IN A CAMPAIGN,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET NAILED ON IT
BY TRUMP OR THE OTHER DEMOCRATS
RUNNING.
ELIZABETH WARREN IS NOW I THINK
GOING TO BE THE FRONT RUNNER.
SHE'S ALLOWING JOE BIDEN TO GET
OVER THIS WITH TRUMP BUT
JOE BIDEN MIGHT NOT BE THE
NOMINEE SO WHAT'S THE QUESTION
THEN?
DO THE INVESTIGATIONS CONTINUE?
>> Juan: WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT WHAT DANA SAID, TALKING
POINT OF THE DAY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, SCARED, AFRAID.
>> Greg: THEY SHOULD BE
SCARED.
I HATE COMPLAINING ABOUT THIS
JOB.
WE HAVE A GREAT JOB.
WE GET PAID TO TALK ABOUT STUFF
THAT THIS STORY JUST BUGS THE
CRAP OUT OF ME BECAUSE IT IS SO
FAKE.
IT'S A POLITICAL STORY
MASQUERADING AS A MORAL, SOCIAL
STORY.
AN ATTEMPT TO TURN HEARSAY INTO
HERESY.
IT'S BECOME SO BIG AND WE HAVE
TO PRETEND AS WE REPORT THIS
THAT TO YOU WE BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY, REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN
FOR US IT'S JUST A CAROUSEL WE
HAVE TO HOP ON AND HOP OFF.
THANK GOD FOR HUNTER BIDEN
BECAUSE THIS IS SO MUCH EASIER
TO UNDERSTAND WHEN HE BECOMES
THE FOCUS.
THE AMERICAN VIEWER, THEY DON'T
CARE ABOUT THE PHONE CALL.
THEY CAN LOOK AT THE TRANSCRIPT
AND SEE WHAT IT IS.
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS NEPOTISM.
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THE
OFFSPRING WHO DID NOTHING
PRODUCTIVE WITH HIS LIFE AND FED
OFF HIS DADDY'S NAME.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT GUY.
EVERYBODY CAN'T STAND HIM AND
HE'S A HOOD ORNAMENT OF THE
SWAMP.
HE IS.
HE'S EVERYTHING BAD AND THE BEST
PART IS THE MEDIA CONCERNED
ABOUT TRUMP'S ANGER YESTERDAY.
IT'S LIKE LIGHTING FIRECRACKERS
IN COMPLAINING ABOUT THE NOISE.
IT'S LIKE GOING TO A FISH
RESTAURANT IN SAYING THIS TASTES
FISHY.
DUDE, YOU CREATED THIS MESS.
YOU'VE BEEN SPENDING THREE YEARS
TRYING TO GET THE BEAR TO SNAP.
I ALSO NOTICED HOW HAPPY THE
MEDIA IS THAT RACHEL MADDOW
FINALLY HAS A STORY.
FOR THE LAST SIX MONTHS, IT'S
BEEN REALLY SAD ON HER SHOW, THE
NUMBERS ARE DOWN BUT NOW SHE'S
ON "THE VIEW."
THERE'S ARTICLES ABOUT HER.
IT'S LIKE HER HOMECOMING.
IT'S LIKE A HOMECOMING DANCE AND
A BAT MITZVAH PUT TOGETHER?
IS THAT WHAT IT'S CALLED?
I'M A CATHOLIC.
I'VE NEVER SEEN THE MEDIA WORK
SO HARD FOR SO LITTLE.
THE SAME MEDIA THAT CHUCKLED
OVER BENGHAZI IN WHICH FOUR
PEOPLE DIED ARE SCREAMING ABOUT
A PHONE CALL.
HOW DID THEY DO IT WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE.
I HATE TALKING ABOUT A BUT
SOMEHOW I WAS ABLE TO DO IT FOR
2 MINUTES.
>> Juan: WHAT ABOUT IVANKA AND
HER SHOE DEAL WITH THE CHINESE?
>> Greg: IT'S AN INTERESTING
QUESTION.
ALL OF TRUMP'S KIDS ACTUALLY
WORK.